[Music]
i grew up in northwest indiana
in a university town surrounded by corn
and soybean fields
and when i was in the fourth grade my
class went on a field trip to the art
institute of chicago
we were ready to see the water lilies
and american gothic
if you're at all familiar with the area
you know that in order to get there
we had to drive through gary indiana
gary was a classic company town founded
by u.s steel
and it was once considered a crown jewel
of the industrial world
called the city of the century people
flocked to this new town with high hopes
and the promise of good jobs
but when my classmates and i drove
through gary on the bus
we saw boarded up windows overgrown
grass
and i remember asking my seat mate where
are the people
over decades of consolidation
outsourcing and process
changes plant shutdown and gary and the
people who work their life too
when i think about gary i think about
the people who left
and the cat and mouse game they must
have had to play chasing jobs that
require their skills
i think about how that becomes harder
and harder to maintain
as jobs leave as skills become obsolete
and when there isn't a clear way to
develop your capabilities
where you are
in 2021 even without a global pandemic
millions of americans are still unable
to fully participate in the economy
and that's due in large part to a
mismatch between the skills that they
have
and the skills and greatest demand and
even further high costs for learning
and dominant paradigms about career
trajectories and about
how and when career learning should
happen
may pose a barrier to folks who might
otherwise invest in their capabilities
and all of that's a shame because
re-skilling at scale
has the ability to help our country
attack the profound
economic inequalities we face
it can also help us realize the full
potential of emerging industries
that need people to fuel their growth
and interestingly reskilling might even
help us recast the way we see ourselves
not as people with fixed abilities
one-trick ponies
but instead is people who are
fundamentally capable of growth
the good news is that we can decide to
develop infrastructure
to make reskilling at scale happen and
while there is absolutely a role for
government and for nonprofits
i'm going to focus on what companies can
do
companies need to be at the center of
re-skilling efforts because
they know their skill set needs and can
forecast those needs
better than anybody companies are also
in many ways
the direct beneficiary of any labor
force advancement
and conveniently companies have direct
access to much of the american workforce
by virtue of being employers so in order
to meet the moment for reskilling there
are
three things companies can do number one
come together to determine their skill
set needs
number two develop programming to teach
those skills
and number three play matchmaker between
learners and programming
and teach taken together
these steps can position our labor force
to skill up
and to participate more fully in the
economy
let's start with number one companies
coming together to determine the skills
that they need within their ranks
having a handle on skill set needs can
help companies refine the scope
of their reskilling efforts to ensure
that they're aligned with
their actual requirements it can also
help learners cut through the noise
and focus on what's actually important
to companies
so in that way having a handle on skill
set needs
can help players on both sides of the
equation align their efforts
a critical piece of this step is that
companies need to come together in order
to do this
and all suggest that they come together
at the industry level given that firms
within industries tend to have
important similarities all players in an
industry
have the ability to benefit when their
labor force is expanded and improved
so if everybody has the ability to
benefit everybody needs to be involved
our second step is for companies to
develop programming to teach the skill
sets that they need
and there are a few ways that they might
do this one approach
is to partner with organizations that
already teach the skills that they're
interested in
so depending on the skill set needs
depending on the target populations that
they're interested in engaging
there may already be a bevy of
non-profit and for-profit
players who provide offerings
colleges and universities may be an
obvious choice for certain companies
they have vast infrastructure for
learning and their bread and butter
is delivering credible learning
experiences at scale
on the other end companies may consider
developing programming from scratch
in certain circumstances they may find
that outside organizations may not be
well equipped
to teach the skills that they're
interested in having
they may also find that outside partners
may not serve the populations that
they're most interested in engaging
so for example many opportunities exist
for
people at the entry level to develop
their skills
but fewer opportunities exist for people
at later stages in their career
as such it may be appropriate for
companies to consider ways that they can
support learners
across their career span
our final step is for companies to play
matchmaker
between learners and programming and
actually implement these programs
and there are two sides of this on the
one end
companies can engage their existing
employees
acting as a facilitator they can help
their employees understand their
strengths
and their interests in the context of
the businesses needs
and then use that information to place
learners on the appropriate pathway
the result is that over time employees
and companies by extension
are able to modulate their capabilities
to meet the demands of the day
so instead of getting laid off employees
can find new purpose
and instead of expensive talent searches
companies can use the talent right in
front of them
the other side of this is companies
engaging perspective talent
you can imagine situations in which it
does make sense for a company to look
outside of its four walls particularly
if it's looking to expand its headcount
under this approach they can act as a
facilitator to help
prospective employees think about their
strengths and interests in the context
of business needs
and then use that information to connect
them to learning pathways
doing so allows companies to make sure
that they're filling all of their seats
and operating at peak capacity
if all of this sounds expensive to you
you're right
but so is recruiting every time you
can't find the skills that you need
in-house according to the society for
human resource management
it costs a u.s company an average of a
little over four
thousand dollars per employee to recruit
and that doesn't include the 40 to 50
days on average
it takes to find that employee
creating a re-skilling regime involves
reallocating the significant talent
investments
that companies are already making an
equally compelling cost though
comes from all of the opportunities not
seized
because companies don't have the
capabilities and capacity in house to
execute
and it's for these reasons that
re-skilling can't just be a pet
initiative
reskilling has the ability to unleash
the full potential of our workforce and
of our industries
and that's why companies from nike to
amazon to walmart
are all making these investments
now i want you to imagine for a moment
being called into your boss's office
you know that your division hasn't been
hitting its numbers despite
your hardest efforts and you also know
that the company would be silly not to
make changes
but when you sit down you're not met
with conversation about a pink slip
or talk about how you and the company
need to go in different directions
instead you're met with a conversation
about you
and the role that you can play in moving
the company forward
by growing your capabilities growing
your know-how
you can be the solution
when we make re-skilling the norm we can
make this situation the norm too
companies don't have to get up and leave
and workers don't have to be the cat
chasing the mouse we can decide to make
this our reality
thank you
you